[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello happy holiday Tuesday nice sweater
Rob oh this whole thing yeah yeah yeah
stretch out stretch out show show those
horses or reindeers reindeer today we
are fortunate enough to be playing some
rocket League yet again
frosty fest has come to rocket league so
it's already started
why yes fun fact today on PlayStation 4
as well as the switch there's a sale for
rocket League I believe it's like $13.99
I'm not mistaken so if you were planning
on trying to pick up rocket League or
play it's on sale as of today on Xbox
one and PC it's gonna be closer to
Christmas so if you're waiting for that
that's news there so this is brought to
you guys by our good friends over at
rocket league so we'll be checking out
frosty fest buying some of these holiday
stuff so you won't go up there show them
that that snowflake currency snowflake
currency how many um see we played a
little bit yesterday I want to say that
Oh hour maybe two hours mm-hmm I was
able to get about 64 of these what's the
currency like snowflake snowflake so
lakes it's like the Halloween event if
you guys played that you earn anywhere
from like three to like seven coins is
roughly what I saw three five or seven
per completed match and you can buy
certain specific things like some of
these toppers is fallen tree angel wings
like the angel wings um I think there's
like a if you go to cold sweater the
second one yeah it becomes like a skin
that you can put on like since I don't
have a ugly sweater maybe I need to buy
that I don't know there's of course like
the the seeker Santa crate and a
decrypter which we're thinking we'll
take we haven't tried this yet you're
gonna buy the crate right sure okay all
right oh you can open it see you don't
need the krypter okay I'm confused with
the Decrypter does alright oh oh okay
you do have a decrypter though okay so
you krypter well you said would buy oh I
already have a I guess it's a crypt her
as a key more or less so I already have
one key way to buy one for 50
as well if you get if you're on the
other menu so now I get it if you didn't
have a Decrypter it'd be a hundred to
open a crate pretty much right because
he's named 52 by the crate then another
50 to get to the Crypt right so you're
gonna pop that one
sure let's pop it good luck I hope you
get what is it legendary is that's the
highest one come on I'd like that gold
yeah that goal yeah Oh keep going it's
like the present right so oh I want a
peppermint banner alright winner is it
does it do something
Oh yellow lights that's sick already
quit that that's festive all right let
me get it on so if I wanted this
peppermint antenna there I'd I need to
play maybe one or two more matches but
I'm not gonna go for these angel angel
wings see this is very appropriate for
aerials you know yeah I mean yeah that's
why your your screens up in mine isn't
because you're gonna go for the aerials
and I am NOT yeah we debated ah yeah
okay good I was worried about that no
not at all man someone else in the
office was gonna play maybe a little
they'll join us later
yeah perhaps perhaps Oh failed to join
that's weird
hold on I got like three invitations for
you so one no that's probably it
okay good I hope so we're good baby are
we yeah you're in let's do some yeah
you're still joining all right okay okay
yes Scotty Daniels Christmas event is
happening in destiny - that is true
already destiny questions I know but for
now we're doing some hot holiday action
in rocket League about hot problem did I
do casual I did do casual that's fine
whatever
I think we still earned them might as
well find out if you earn diamond casual
I finalist you cash will do catch and
then we'll do competitive get some
warm-up matches well warm up it is a
little chilly out up here I like you up
the mister music's there yeah mister
yeah I got a lot of Rick and Morty stuff
so like oh my wheels are also Morty yeah
there were some like I haven't earned
any actual like holiday stuff
yet post-match have you know I have seen
some people scoring on us with the the
big ol Christmas kind of like holiday
goal scoring thing I like that I have
yet to get a cool yeah explosion goal
animation the one we just saw yesterday
I really liked is it's like a free so it
freezes the ball and then it explodes
yeah a little bit of an implosion don't
worry we will be playing some games job
PC we want to make sure you guys knew
how that stuff worked how the currency
works also wanted to make sure you guys
knew about the hot sale going on on
PlayStation 4 as well as the switch
today yeah switch man by % off in North
America and the EU pretty good time to
get into rocket League I would rock the
league on switch is pretty good it is
all right here we go we did Mohnish yeah
you're on it
you know what's awkward I don't have
audio I could plug it into my controller
though you hear at least my on yeah
weird stuff matter yeah we got 200 ping
that's sick yikes maybe it's who we
could oh you know what did you did you
change your regions for SMS game search
are you sure yeah well my searching was
okay we'll find out after this match oh
we're back that was weird
maybe he's just a little spike a little
spike in the beginning it's fine I
didn't feel it though I didn't do that
like crazy you know how like sometimes
it creates Oh too much no is it I
touched it I should have a second it's
coming around yonder that guy is afk oh
no we got that hot pan again are you
sure I don't feel it though right now oh
there it is I see a little thing you
know that's weird though all right we'll
have to check the the regions my hope is
that you just happen to have all of them
on and that were somewhere else but I
don't make sense though because they're
ping would be bad too right
it's a little interesting Oh what to say
up there we go well this is working out
I guess I feel bad though for them if it
is because of it here no you're right
where are us West yes yeah I mean what I
can tried to do is replug you into that
other internet that blue one yeah oh
there's lying whoo are you flying I'm
flying I'm warping I'm very much working
oh this is not how rocket League is
played should we abort we can why don't
you just back out real quick and I'll go
to camera maybe it's cause we're getting
spammed friend okay my friend I will
I'll switch it for you hold on and then
why don't you once I can get to this
screen here real quick mm-hmm I'll go
full camera mm-hmm
then I'm going to so that you can turn
off your notifications here hmm and I'm
also gonna fix you okay let's honor that
[Music]
if you're just joining us we're playing
rocket League and just hang in there
you hang right in there we're gonna be
up and rolling in in a few seconds
so it's on our end for sure it happens
[Music]
where'd you get that you found it oh I
wonder if they make eggnog in a can good
call chastity it's because I was muted
yeah so Rob's fixing that you didn't
want to hear me say this is this was
gross who just don't drink on nitro cold
brew warm
all right cool you good all right so
we're gonna go back to game pit beer
hopefully all right I gotta I gotta get
back into this now hold on the joys of
we're doing it live Rob we sure are
no prob no problem make up for it oh did
you do a hot invite I just invited I was
sick all right I see that invite Oh dip
some guy just showed up
Oh somebody part-time look at these
fellow game spotter those wheels I don't
leave my party to get those cool all
right so hopefully we're good now okay
let's do some competitive threes
oh we're again now we're into it oh the
war gonna have to go through the
thingies anyways you know what I mean
we're gonna have to go through Oh so
select region yeah you were probably
right there dude
yeah well we're still in a uswest server
though so I'm writing triples standard
left one more yeah we got three now bro
why oh my God thank you Jesus
it's okay middle of the day Rob hasn't
had enough coffee yet
Eric fix your mic I fixed it
what are we drinking uh this is a warm
cold brew I'll try it another sip Rick
James says eggnog and a cans sounds
disgusting I don't know I don't know who
does that mr. meeseeks yeah sure is
can you sorry if that was annoying
no I did it too dude all right I feel I
feel hopefully better won't you check
your ping oh maybe I'm the I'm the odd
man out now oh I'm good okay okay we're
good oh oh oh oh Reilly's oh no I have
bad ping but that's fine holy moly
where's the goalie they just spawned in
there oh oh oh I'm having a grand old
time over here maybe you two should just
play and I'll just recheck yep
I did nothing I'm just sitting here
lagging in the back here don't mind me
weird I can fix this
I might DC though what do you think what
do you think oh yeah I got 300 ping
right now I'm gonna fix my stuff you
keep going I'll keep I'll do my best
oh jeez yeah Oh your best is all we can
ask for mm-hmm
[Music]
nope I don't like that Oh Oh all right P
mics it was pure excitement oh hey guys
what's up uh-huh
oh wow reconnect me yeah you could still
be good okay oh my god it said oh that's
not where where the ball is not for you
well I did a real sweet move see this is
what you don't want to do you don't want
to do with a little bit of a self set
there how old the phone here how am I
even still connected
I totally unplugged my internet to then
plug in like minutes oh sorry
I'll get credit while you to be three
these guys that's how good they are so
sometimes your oh my god oh yeah that's
right so small brick said a cat oh [ __ ]
the same three that played during the
switch version that's right okay I
haven't like the best of the best of the
best internet right now I can't like I'm
gonna close it and come back in this is
on us but good thing we have Rob stream
up there gonna what
how does he have that I don't know
alright at least it's on the stream
that's good work Merry Christmas
oh-ho-ho actually I have the old Merry
Christmas umm thingy the the boost
what's that
is it present it's like presents that
shoot out of your exhaust well here he
goes for the set I'm trying to remember
like any other Christmas type of stuff
my Peters bag that's a nice shot
I would got that just say no shot
accidentally looks I'm reconnecting stay
on target get your ass back in a on
target don't worry I feel it did you
quit oh you're in oh I quit the game too
I had to close the app because it was
like oh I'm good I'm good I'm good
everything is great I'm so surprised
that's really awesome I'm surprised
you're able to get like all the way back
in good functionality oh here we go
let's all go for it get out my way yeah
blow him up oh I did not see that guy
coming oh [ __ ] stops it but I got a
little piece
oh yeah kind of
nope man I wish I was really good at
aerials that would make my life so happy
yeah you know it's a lot of work you
gotta do - Oh baby
it's the hole man it's the ability to
like give it and just change such a
direction you know I mean like you can't
always in midair be boostin you know
what I mean like you have to take apart
a veteran and just pivot around I still
haven't gotten the hang of it that's why
I just try to be a setup guy we can do
some private matches later oh we did it
last night yeah but we need to kind of
we're gonna showcase the mode and I
don't I don't think you earn those hot
creds in private mode so we're gonna
play probably some some matches here for
a bit and then at the very end of the
stream the last maybe half an hour we'll
do something we'll do some private games
here absolutely
okay keep it keep it keep it up oh oh oh
there for the taking how are you see I
told you all I can do is be the setup
guy butts all right oh we're back
instead of we're down we were down a
player for a you guys were holding the
fort strong remember guys in na and EU
today there's a discount on rocket
League believe 25% off
also frosty fest is going on until like
January the second if I recall correctly
yeah
13 days oh that's high
there is PD reminding does that include
DLC uh I believe so I'd have to
double-check for yourself after this or
someone in chat I know
chasidy will will tell us I have no
confidence in my area oh that's good I
can do that oh yeah you can score off it
all I ran out boost last second Oh Oh
give me a little oh yeah touch right
nope I failed you still IV on it he's on
it Oh didn't matter he had a block he
had a good new old block on it
I guess I'm gonna fight ourselves a nice
little game here oh that kind of save Oh
Joyce oh I always do that go Peter it's
a set oh they're both there okay
maybe oh that scared me Jim gone oh no I
just left the goal it was a it was a
questionable move it's coming off the
wall hot too hot probably oh please oh
I'm so sorry
PC Brown oh oh I was too high
Oh get it in there yeah all right all
right all right yeah it's been a while
for me since I played played the league
since the switch stream but it's always
a good time when you're with your boys
or your your gals learn some big goals
you also know it's been a while when you
when you come back and you're asked to
rank or play some matches to get back
into a rank yeah because a season change
well that's good ol that's a good goal
George oh yeah
but yeah I feel like um even the the
switch version was pretty good playing
handheld it took a little bit getting
used to but it's pretty good yeah oh
yeah with a controller you're you're
fine but it's the handheld it's it's
tricky was fine it's fine it's like not
it's not like playing a first-person
shooter right yeah yeah that was tough
that's all I'm doing was to get you hot
dogs hot dogs oh I got six there did you
get anything
see I don't know maybe I haven't uh a
prompt that I turned off maybe you hit X
or something or no I I should it should
be showing that I got some but yeah we
got six uh snowflake currencies at that
time find a new match Rob damn Rick
James says he has 1700 hours and rocket
League whoa I mean we're really not too
far off
Oh yet sorry gotta get him to queue for
the next match it's too excited ring
chat alright good good start I did
nothing there but I was out half the
match so you know you did something yeah
I didn't get zero points you didn't get
zero points what's up zebras legend
what's up to everybody in in chat thanks
for tuning in yeah thank you
mmm-hmm I was trying to look at options
for you to see if there was anything
yeah I was thinking about doing it there
but okay that happens did I lose you
you're still in know maybe because I
joined me match oh that would make sense
find you
I should probably can't assistant this
works yeah yeah see if I can hop back
into yo party yeah you should check to
see if there's anything like an option
blocking you from seeing that currency
okay I'm on yin I'm a skater all right
you can do a post-match though that
might be a good time right back in it
eleven more matches to go hey wait we
won that we're in an online game no no
someone else is no serious Peter needs
to bounce out he's not gonna know that
just that garage oh you know what I need
to switch my boost to be more festive to
match the holiday season maybe I'll do
that too real quick you got to have that
one right the Xmas one I have some Xmas
I have that kind of stuff too I mean I
guess some of that the vintage stuff on
Santa hat I got that boost on oh I'm in
the wrong car deals yeah some limited
wheels festive here oh I got that
holiday whole okay well I am
I'm decked out in my holiday gift set
maybe I have a cow do a little bit of
Santa little Santa action I go uh-huh
uh-huh yep yeah this is good Easter egg
that's not right yeah I can do that but
the other end of the Arts
let me see hold on real quick
he's in another game their unparalleled
his skills all right let me get some a
couple more matter and I can get these
hot wings yeah like an angel sorry I got
a no you're good get this thing up
apparently chef I are try firing up a
match now oh it's fire up a match you're
in an online game now Wow what I don't
know do we want to remake the party
vendors yeah or kick once you kick I'm
gonna boot all y'all and start again I'm
gonna play my favorite song while we
wait I've missed it which one rocket
Shan for you or just move on to a
doubles don't you do hot doubles were
quick while I set this up how are you in
an online game I don't know I'm a
phantom no it says
see if he can start an online game while
I'm doing it well I'm waiting
are you searching um you to you to play
one real quick he says he's in an online
game I'm just gonna play on myself I
gotta do it
screw it maybe he still is playing in
that other match I'll just do doubles be
hilarious if it's like you're an online
man Oh realizes bronze I'm out
yeah bronze bro I am a bronze bro but I
still have to like because the season
changed right
Oh ro hi we still dominate the streets
yeah we we are what they would call
what's the what's the right word you're
not trolling you're you're rolling no no
no no you know how like you you fake
you're like really low level and then
like you play really weak people to stop
them forget the term Brian I used to do
it in Starcraft all the time I'm a
terrible person
I think people they said doing I was
drunk that's why it's kind of funny
could you would people do it in this
game I don't know it so slurping in
smurfier that's the right Roy yeah
smurfing thank you I also thought of it
as you're saying it
I never changed my inventory so it's
weird to like hear anything different
here Santa jingles Santa all that
who else and I said wasn't there hot set
up I say
ah
all righty I'm gonna try to hop back in
to help you out sir not in this one and
I started no I know okay I know you know
what I'll do I'm gonna buy a crate or
sure no I'm for short I'll buy a crate
next one to see if I can get some nice
holiday I blew it
you blew it Doug maybe I have a
Decrypter I doubt it though how long is
the frosty best a thing we can only buy
five decrypt errs though January January
what January date is January the 2nd
January 2nd 13 days is what it says on a
countdown really in Game three more than
that or maybe the 13 days left
that's what as I meant 25% off though
today on PlayStation and the Nintendo
switch there will be a deal coming down
the road for Xbox and PC started the
11th at 5 which is last week last week
and it runs until January the second 10
and Pacific so hop into frosty fest get
those sweet snowflake currencies coins
from finishing matches and buy yourself
some nice holiday themed stuff
oh yeah run it feels bad man
I have no key I need a hot oh sorry dude
oh oh dude those wheels are sick not the
Christmas wreath ones but the wonderment
ones alright
four more and I can buy a key so nice
work all right
yeah don't worry
yeah Peter we have something we got you
some weird weird stuff there on our end
though for sure's really have it sorted
for the most part that one guy yeah
something like that I guess see he was
Hugh's on the case yeah oh yeah like a
pool she'll pull shot it's like if
you're not gonna get it I'm gonna force
your car into it oh that guy just that
guy my just my fault he says my fault no
problem I say merry goals that's correct
yeah I would say for the most part to
you like through all our time of playing
rocket League I don't feel like the
community in general has been like that
toxic you know for for online
competitive game I think for the most
part people are pretty good about it
the most toxic it ever is I almost
cracked my voice is when is when it's
actually these scenarios where I'm
playing with like doubles with the
random huh and I just have a real [ __ ]
like there there wasn't get really bad
though it has to be really bad and often
times it's me like playing in the
morning like Saturday morning I'm trying
to like get my brain fired up and I'm
just screwing over Rando after Rando and
but even still mostly be you're right
though say like they do that no problem
I just like the chat wheel is pretty
good at free solid yeah
no other game has honestly mastered this
baby oh no I screwed that up so bad it's
okay that other guy didn't know what to
do like no other game has mastered Wow
all right let's not talk to you right
now it's a quick chat is this is just so
solved in this game nice nice work
get clear
it's okay it's okay don't be defeated
where you going no hanging out well
banana are you scoring on yourself no
okay oh this guy's trying to score on us
too oh wait I know I'm really confused
yeah now I get where you're soaring I'm
so confused
I thought I had a right oh my god mind
games I was playing the other team Oh
beautiful beautiful
didn't matter did not matter well edit
that out oh yeah
I need that easy banner with the
calculator yeah you like that so sweet
but everyone's diet oh I'm full shot him
sorry
fine oh this guy this wall wall play
spider-man is the ho ho the Santa hat or
is it's this no no it's the one we'll
call it it's the boost let's just say
don't score any more goals so we keep
gettin ya fair just play keep-away
unless you do a sick goal like right now
where were you the long con yo that's
right that was the longest of cons
SantaCon Gee Gee Gee Gee
whoa I just talked about how the
community is great and you're I didn't I
did not I said GG they don't know good
less they're watching the stream
apologies I'm just kid I kid I kid
what's up rocky in the YouTube chat
hello dam Rob carry the team yeah he did
Eric's in there okey-dokey artichokey
Opie oh let's say Peter to you uh Eric I
am I'm super oh no way any 3595 it's 35
from the hot wings
alright let's get some invites going
here sounds good hot wings that does not
sound good right now really
it sounds great to me invites sent oh
look at my festive banner look at banner
Michael you got a banner oh yeah you do
yeah oh oh but I got a matching hat baby
alright the teams in I got that matching
Santa hat what it was what is a boy over
there doing he's not repping the Santa
hat dude I guess he doesn't appreciate
oh he's switching right now this guy
he's switching let's just Q he can keep
saying hey try wearing a Christmas hat
you jackass
maybe he doesn't have one you know
that's actually probably yeah there have
to be easy to get you'd have to be
playing during what Christmas of last
year this is nothing you map there is a
there's a new one I think though it's
like Santa's backyard
what's up Joseph I don't know why I'm
still drinking you got nothing else to
drink maybe some salty tears from the
orange team game
oh you're by yourself right now standard
just like my personal life dang
Oh oh my god oh my god
I did not see that coming after all that
[Applause]
all right he did all of that crazy stuff
but then he misses this like I don't
bought I don't buy it
today this this might be an early
forfeit I'm not I've no one wall run you
know what you're right May gotta elevate
our game
maybe it's my controller okay kind of
stop that no no the guy in it is on it
Peters on it oh oh wow oh it's why I
still screwed it up all right that's it
I got it
all right that's it I gotta play with my
eyes open
Oh Peter missed it too crazy Edwards
this guy's this guy's rogue he's using
bats during Christmas holidays season
I wasn't able to I've only been able to
earn currency during snow fest I haven't
been able to get any crates or anything
like that during I like postgame not
sure if anyone else's experiences you
know but so far has been snowflake
currency for us you can buy the crates
for 50 currency and then it's like
another 50 to get a decrypter unless you
already have a decrypter or a key but
decrypter is basically yeah but you can
all caught let's get that out of here oh
sorry I was you were a trencher out of
the way I know I was gonna bring it up
the field it's fine that's why we just
haven't coordinated yet edit that out
that was a save
this is not good Paul shot
oh [ __ ] I just hit Peter okay we're good
we're good we're good run it dug up
sorry but if you're not gonna go
someone's got oh oh oh it was too hot
oh crap Peter what the bicycle Oh one
touch Oh Peter it's hot spicy spicy
unless they're spicy meatball oh that's
not actually that good that was actually
a bad thing I think oh gosh go Peter get
it out of here
we're just waiting
oh no oh no oh we're good either gotta
save on that what a save
oh come on baby oh no one's home to slam
slamma-jamma oh what a jerk
oh no it's lined up for that guy nice oh
my god please don't save it dang you
okay we've solidified we just can't get
any office oh that's all you right yes
all right here we go here we go here we
go here we go who comes to come back
later Josh what later Josh Josh all set
go that a but I think so some type of
emoji has an emoji but that's cool all
right
damn this is a tense game my hands are
sweaty you can't you can't feel or see
that but they are sweaty sweaty oops all
right she's okay they're trying to do
big tricks Oh eat unless you get it down
here uh no me and Peter collided in the
air and all like I'm messing with me oh
gosh
we got a hot minute I'm gonna try to do
some wall play here I got a piece which
is all I can ever ask for when I'm
trying to do some wall play
oh yeah he's he's heating it to their
side for us hot collusion please oh crap
I just went past it and I got blown up
but no that didn't help I was trying to
blow that guy up to get to the ball and
Wow
that's a dead egg I guess ah I just
drove right by it I couldn't see in the
smoke ah hey well we can score two goals
real fast right I think so oh that's
that's looking hot only I didn't miss
it's fine we got a score right Hampton
oh that's a good goal forfeit options no
it's a forfeit don't give them the
satisfaction but we'll edit that out
later these are supposed to be for
rankings we had a chance though damn
look at that scho right Oh dip God you
see that little ghost topper though that
was pretty cool well we just play some
hypnotised three little gold guys that's
that's good all right here we go here we
go rebound rebound redemption you're
gonna get it oh did we just lose what
player maybe you left straight left do
we need a venue I mean whatever we'll
get a maybe you just rage quit on us
Oh same map yeah we got it we got a
who do we pick up here now he's back all
right
weird we got trick'd defending what
let's check that replay I okay it was my
fault for not being there but I swore
Peter was gonna hit the ball and he hit
it in our goal okay so therefore I was
like already like making my way because
I thought Peter had it and then no
problem no problem no problem and then
he found a way to like back tap it in oh
oh I'm sorry it probably would hit him
anyway yeah
oh but Peters got it oh that's all you
get out of the way no come back get back
Oh Lord we're good
that was so risky oh sorry you go oh
dang it oh sorry I'm walking Oh God
we're man we deserve to get scored on
right now full shot just what a hot mess
I blew sewing up if there's at least
that oh no he said it oh no I okay all
right I'll explain myself no it doesn't
matter no I like it I like legit oh yeah
I actually thought it was gonna be wide
oh that's it that's the animation I just
wanted I wanna score
oh yeah that nice one I love it yeah we
were pointing on ps4 right now there is
a mentioned there's a sale today 25% off
it's also on switch - we're having a
grand old time here it'd be a little bit
better
we were we were winning oh he said it I
know I'm not there though
sure it's my help up nope oh we just
left ourselves exposed pro nice nice
nice
I totally whipped but it was part of the
long con maybe why not oh I thought he's
gonna hit it crap I got a piece I'm
going for the banana yeah we need it we
need a goal here we need something
morale boosts all right oh that's good
that's real good bounce it bounce it
bounce it I can't don't touch it don't
touch it I won't I was mainly talking to
them as a sloppy dirty go we'll take it
though
Peter going in reverse Randy bo-bandy
you play better after a couple beers
yeah probably that's the thing is is
once you once you get past a couple
beers then you play like garbage and you
just get heated well that that's what we
call a witch City oh nice save I didn't
touch it
he just whipped oh he's he's making some
big plays
no it's wide someone please get time I'm
trying PC Brown is flying right now I'm
just getting shocked oh whoa
ah Shran the corner you got some time
it's still wide I missed it I missed
that one too
Oh baby oh yeah the old fade them all to
come over and then get scored long go
are you a raptor or sometimes bird I did
wings oh oh yes right
nice yeah that was all him
how long ago job to go back on long time
to go
what I don't know I was trying to read
that he scored that all time
Peter Peter does this thing where he
just mashes predictive text and PS oh
really
oh yeah you know that and it's just the
funniest in-game chat ever go read
alright well we're looking we're looking
alright are you kidding me they almost
happen again
oh yeah I was like I'm gonna choke you
guys got that he does oh that's looking
kind of hot oh you're gonna get it
alright let me try to well pop up there
oh I got fancy is jocking them
I got fancy alright that's alright
sometimes you gotta get fancy oh boy
[ __ ] I don't have the guts okay he miss
Peter's okay Peters on the case nope oh
my god it's okay I do that last minute
let's come around hot no it's not okay
nice don't touch it
oh is that gonna be a long goal you got
that got it
No I got a piece
oh not like this
I would get well at least from the from
that story okay okay maybe not maybe not
maybe I'm here I'm here
Peters confusing the hell out of me
just keep it in the corner yeah baby
whoop solid defense defense and win
championships don't forget that kids
there it is all right for them hot wings
and I got a crate oh did you know but
it's not the Santa Claus great though oh
so you can't get crates from the post
game we I haven't gotten a santa one
though a Christmas one are we going to
the main menu I don't have enough for
the wings okay all right then we'll keep
going until you get enough for the the
wings
I think another I think I'm not are they
bronze or silver we're nothing right now
we're hot on ranked we're yeah I don't
ranked it's been a while we're coming
back to a new season a fresh season yeah
we got a place in uh oh he's the party
leader hey yeah I said that you're on
the main menu and I'm getting kicked out
here now so maybe go main menu okay I'm
pretty sure the wings are 25 together
they're 35 dude I've been eyeing them oh
yeah you're right I in them I wanna bite
the krypter it'd be really it'd be
really cool if they like oh I'm one away
I'm gonna open my crate would I do that
all right well I'm just gonna keep
moving on in next up
man we are we are really missing some
we're really missing some ascetics here
from another player on the team just in
a Santa hat we're missing a frickin
Santa hat Cotter Gomez says I'm training
to get better at this game yeah there's
definitely it's one of those games that
is great for everyone but has a high
skill skill level cap you know like the
Kenobi's of the world and people that
compete in the rocket League tournaments
I I'm so crazy I'm sucked to the
subreddit and I mean I wouldn't I would
recommend it but then again sometimes I
don't because they have really amazing
gifts that like okay we're good that or
they're they're actually just amazing to
watch but sometimes you watch a couple
you're like I wish I was that good
however there are a few times I've seen
really awesome tip videos from guys who
are like more or less showing like just
like this simplicity techniques with
like the simplicity of like having like
doubles I've where should you be with in
correspondence to like your other player
like never be in the same spot at the
same time you know like always make a
move and then head back like I don't
want to warm and right you used to say
and over yeah like make a move but
always fall back so you can you can
count on your other teammate to like
replace you and attack opposed to having
that vulnerable moment when you both
strike on the opposing goal and then no
one's at home and then you're screwed
like that's off right yeah
Oh Peter got blown up give me a little
bit of a pop there oh wow
good oh that good dude nah he's Peter a
night kiss into there that's cute watch
maybe you see where you play I'm
watching for it I'm looking for the kiss
there the lady in the [ __ ] where's the
lady on the trip oh that's hot
yeah yeah it was a combined combined
effort here boom about Tamra settings uh
we went when Kirk Renault he was the the
hottest of the hot he's still really
good I'm sure we looked at his settings
and he had obviously camera shake off I
think his fov wasn't that different he
had it like 92 or something like that
which is just to up form I think
standard which is 9000 they sorry I
shouldn't have gone out oh that worked
out so well try to attack that ball
midair
the other thing I do is I have my roll
like that
tied oh well yeah we go let me give tips
while I play a game I have my like
midair role tied to my stick so I can
like adjust give it a little more fine
ass yeah there Chris waters the taste
Besh's back yeah I guess so I don't know
man
it's a it comes and goes it's not as
consistent as it used to be oh I think
it's like every day from my annoys back
let me kill this guy screw it dang it oh
no we got no one in the cold but there I
had that you're swarming airs swarming
like a pack of wild vultures yeah
or hyenas hyenas
Oh Peter with it no oh yeah don't mind
me just like sky when I was an
incredible shot and watch me just
circling inside the goal regardless I
think this guy did like a I looked
cooler him from my angle Steve Dexter
with a D school that was good yeah what
happened we were slipping I know we were
talking too much about some hot tips
yeah as we lose oh come on we're not
losing I know I it's tied we just let
some goals in most of those being my
fault oh please Oh Peter was almost oh
I'm out there back up
I may have just fine that's why this one
better than leaving it where it was
sorry I know you know that's why are you
worth oh he's oh I so had that block all
right it's okay we want these games to
the you know challenging
what's up Andrew Selby how goes it
that got nowhere
alright I'll take it you take it
sorry I put it back over oh but it's not
going in though
Oh a nice play like no way to get it out
trouble
oh they kind of said it don't know if
anyone's there that was screwed Peter up
there on that banana
I'm sorry hit that boost
Oh
it kind of worked out but I can get a
Joe nice okay 30 seconds plenty of time
down to the wire this is where we shine
oh yeah all you as mentioned this is
when we shine I don't know what they're
doing
yeah the goalie there and then you know
bad angle well he like well they made
the wrong reach for it at all chase oops
yeah
oh no [ __ ] I'm there
Wow thank God for booth oh thank God for
booth huh oh man
uh-uh yeah uh-huh
oh so pretty it's coming back around I'm
not there I was to heat up I you know
boost
oh nice little scoop by that guy
scooped is your
I blew me up
Oh Mamma Mia my mommy I alright put in
there in their corner this I'm gonna
treat this like hockey we're just gonna
try to have possession are you gonna get
there now we're good we're good we're
good
think oh that's not good
nice Oh
but only I was better at aerials I think
that would have been a goal oh no oh no
I can't
yeah no problem
nice no problem just like we drew it up
you know well they mean they made the
classic one on 101 no no that's a lot of
presents because they were always
swarming that boost is a little bit
annoying so someone to chat yeah I can
see that yeah I kind of gree I'm gonna
change it up what changed it does oh but
you get your wings right oh we got 9 I
get my wing let's bounce out of this
menu hopefully he knows that or he's
gonna end up in an online match I want
to learn to fly
we've been playing some really close
intense matches here coming down to the
wire
oh yeah where do I go to opening so for
the crate you go to the main special
event there and go all the way to the
bottom
reading wards and all the way to the
bottom no but that's the buying the
chest what you ask how do I open it I
have the key oh you got to go to
inventory no go back out go to special
10th my back ok inventory and go to
Crate Bumble no sorry one more output
create bundles yeah and then you should
be able to open a crate be don't wait
you just got a regular quick create them
no I bought the Santa one and I bought
the Decrypter
okay then try to go to inventory into it
there oh go to garage
manage inventory yeah there you go
secret santa crate oh there yeah yeah a
what
oh I can use the Decrypter there you go
yes I'll tell you what guys what'd I get
in a second or I'll just equip it whammy
whammy I got wrecked
I got a reg couch what'd you get I got a
decal I'll put it on ooh that looks real
fun it's only a blue though man I'm
living that poverty life you got a
purple I didn't get a purple I got
snowflakes that works let me get this
decal on real quick wait what was it
only on a certain card are you ready no
it's on the octane hold on I got to put
this decal on and I've never really used
the octane but yeah I'm ready it's on
right now look at that look at Eric's
decal there you know what I like that
because it's it's not so tied down to
the holiday season you know what I mean
like frankly I can't just wear like I
shouldn't just buy anything sweater
they'll be sweater which would work like
you can't work Santa hat every day cold
sweaters 50 yeah I like that what are
you gonna get next Oh am I gonna get
next probably the sweat the sweater
giving so the cold sweater there's two
types there huh well one was a was the
banner yeah yeah I don't care much for
banners yep so frosty fest is going on
just so y'all know you get snowflake
currencies for finishing a game also oh
my God look at this it's a hot sale
going on for PlayStation as
in attendance which oh my god my wings
are so amazing I real man I feel like
I'm playing so much better with this
decal I feel like I'm really flying now
I feel like I've gained 5 horsepower I
really feel like a better player oh [ __ ]
let's put it to use
Wow way to go me just warming up I
thought we were good Peter had this nice
little save there but maybe it's just
skipping skip it skip it skip it skip it
skip it it's okay I was nowhere to be
seen so that's fine like I said we like
to build up the suspense on the drama
here only to come back and steal victory
at the end of it right
ooh Wow oh dude I was actually trying to
get the ball that's fine in your angel
wings were in the way
oh yeah that was pretty wasn't it looked
pretty you look like you're flying
maybe yes oh yeah yeah well no that's a
song baby
oh okay okay
try to get that thing out of here nope
not there these guys are persistent huh
they're swarming though we got a right
finish him
ah yeah oh no try it I should go since
all right sorry
did you drink a Red Bull maybe that's
why he has wings no I didn't have my my
daily Red Bull yeah he's got the
peppermint we also think that guy oh
lucky yeah I know right
oh that's not good
oh he's Duke and me gotta make a play
you got to make a place exactly what the
what that announcer said what a play oh
[ __ ] oh my god whose side are you on my
fault yes you set it back into the
middle we'll edit that out you keep
saying we edit our streams down well
remember that awesome save I had which
one that's the cut we'll cover it today
sorry I missed it
figure if there was ever a time to make
crazy plays would be now I'm just
getting used to these wings oh my god
Peter what are you doing jock you out
hey yeah he is a he's a ball hawk he's
everywhere he just dropped me too
well I'm along with wings Oh
we got plenty of time though plenty of
time we just gotta get one here get the
get the goals flowing [ __ ]
of God
oh that's coming back out this ah nice
oh damn you mr. Howell
oh come on now that's like a close
you never need to say save by the keeper
I'm honored you're on it won't work
Oh Peter out of nowhere
what thought snow is not safe
oh no it's gonna be a drop though
nothing oh that is though get me freakin
right-side up
nice stop by Peter yeah Oh Peter I'm
sorry God is it so stressful by the way
I'm out of the way David sorry Peter
we're just uh
we'll just dang it
let's not get shut out no nothing's free
here no shoutouts here yeah you can
trade stuff to write like you know a
little bit more about that but I'm you
can't indeed I think the Decrypter had
said that I could trade but that's fine
oh yeah
all right redemption redemption yikes
I wasn't a good match what can I say hey
that guy has my car only cor feels like
you deaf feels like you earn more when
you win can't confirm or deny that but I
feel like when you do win
now it makes a deck jerkin what's up
Calvin yeah I kind of wish you could do
the garage stuff in here yeah oh dude
we're those guys is that just silver is
that platinum my silver Hisle no that
looks like platinum dude they didn't
play like platinum though maybe they're
faking it all right here we go this is
gonna be the one this is the one
this is it Oh have to go hey don't you
dare Peter try steal my glory learn to
fly I wish I could tell you that this
was planned it was not you wanted it
oh I lie the way I am Oh glad they're
not showing my feet I could whip twice I
almost let them score it then Peter had
me on a great angle you get one more
touch when what what how about one more
okay I'll nope I won't sorry I should go
too oh there you go oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh this guy [ __ ]
sorry jocks
yeah come on baby oh
oh that just that was bad scoop it he
does he's stupid
thank you Peter oh [ __ ] I'm there
Oh sassette Thank You other guy on the
team props to the snare band top
off-limits top off-limits family from
hell blue team gang a little upset there
huh
bung slipper oh this is not good
oh it's high it's high high in the sky
Oh Oh scheisse watch me just come from
the top here and whipper ruski not much
you can do there but get good but get
good
there's practically no in there to pop
up to soft pop oh come on nice nicely
played
Oh Peter why are you putting it back in
the corner over the top get it
are you the Punisher Oh
learn to fly bouncing a please oh oh
that's another one though ah debatable
nope it's a pop-up right there
okay that's fine Oh there for that Oh
kind of that is something that's high
but it's oh and I saved oh no oh yeah oh
yeah okay give me a little balance miss
it hope he misses it oh okay I try to
push it away
oh this jerk cars everywhere man
f
yep oh no it's too low no no uh got no
verticality to that can you can't scoop
that yeah you're scooping it oh you got
no boost huh now no boost oh oh cool
shot oh I got blown up ourselves a
full-time goalie here okay okay oh come
on baby it's slow roll up all right I
might be on the case nope Oh get it out
of there Rob
oh nice I didn't know you like blocked
it a little bit which oh boy yep it's a
hot set oh now how do you get that safe
oh [ __ ]
nice you're all over the place right now
in a good way oh is that gonna go in
oh sorry well you're good Oh Shepherd
what was that I don't know if I said him
it's getting real stressful yeah this
one goal lead is is a real thing right
now it's not enough is it I don't know I
would like I would like a nail in the
coffin goal Oh Oh that ass well that's
good oh that's good
you go for it yeah
that's something
Oh lemonhope zipper darn it I'm going
back all the way back were chillin oh
man I had a nice little set to Peter I
thought he was gonna slam dunk that like
I'm monster he look at me everything
I'm the slowpoke though I ride hot Kurt
oh so you only it's random so you only
got three but I got six oh I got a giant
panda
yeah it's ran oh and if it depends on
how you do the man well wait you had
some days you got six yeah I got sick
hey you play better than me
I didn't that dude look at the score you
play barely barely should we do an amaz
yeah whoo no mas por farm or so yeah
frosty fest if you guys didn't know came
out last week
still running now until this January the
second also there's a sale going on
PlayStation 4 as well as whoa as well as
switch 25% off so if you haven't
committed to rocket League I've been
watching a lot wanted to get into it for
the holiday season now is the time to
kind of get into it yeah it's a fun time
you can split screen so you know if you
want to bring that over play with the
you know your your cousin's your niece
your nephews your dad your mom it's a
real whoa that's weird it's a it's a
game that can be picked up by anybody
but you know difficult to master
which is cool yeah you're you're in
doubles that's either okay cool ooh we
got all right we're in competitive then
that sure our competition
all right this is the how to go out on a
bang Rob or it's gonna be one of those
one more situations you or me me I'll go
okay you go oh it was bad I did a real
bad idea on my part
yeah I think I'm having a bad idea -
okay great start Chris start skip it
skip it nah dude I flew out there trying
to grab it earlier wouldn't I shouldn't
have ooh he's got a nice salt banner
it's okay he'll be the one salty after
this Oh
ooh thank you for that I was a rocket
I just wanted me
you got the boost too which is not good
Wow all right got it out of here at
least I try to go get it I'm gonna stay
kind of behind in trail yeah back in
their corner gonna try to to get you a
set here okay I should have committed
it's really hard to tell like if you
should commit or not because like yeah
if they whip it you're gonna get the
gold but I feel like if you
they don't whip it then you're in for
some big trouble oh that's good I like
this it's still there oh oh he got a
piece Sharkboy what's he doing on land
that's a good question Rob he just wants
to be like Airy oh she just wants to be
human you're by yourself right now I'm
stuck in the air okay you put it in the
corner at least skip back I hate this
car I blame the car yeah you know you
could kind of blame it on the car you
could I'm not I'm not directly opposed
to that no I mean like you know like
sometimes you don't have a good feel for
the car I totally agree that just to
some extent oh sure boy
I have no idea where you are that was a
close Juke
oh yeah yeah yeah that's just an easy
goal man they're both out of the oh come
on come on the slowest the slowest
aerial in the world uh feels bad man but
if we win I guess it doesn't matter
honey barely got it I just feel like I'm
not playing very well though you know
like but if we win it ultimately doesn't
really matter all right I'm on the case
oh you got a piece that's not good
I don't know what that did either
come on roll in oh nice dude I think he
helped us hit it in though it hit the
lip I had just enough boost to get it by
him that Sharkboy see right there I
think what everybody came out and what
it came out yeah maybe would have came
out for sure
oh that's in I don't know what that guy
is doing he's trying to do some trick
was he I thought why look look he just
like a flip I don't know if you can see
it buddy just like like I like a little
flip thing you see that little flip
action then he like avoided it I don't
know
well no but Sharkboy here goes right for
the boost in the beginning yeah but he
has confidence that has got your mean
you don't do that you're mean
oh you go sorry you still don't do that
my doubles not in do blaze never oh god
I wish nice he's not there which is good
oh that's just got just want to get it
over there leapfrog okay I got this
I am not there please aah Sharkboy the
consistent player and then get pile we
got a couple more that CC that swarm
attack see their replay oh man no I miss
it yeah I tried to give you guys the
angle all right I like it when they both
whiff and then we get an easy goal
that's the problem with double
committing I feel like you that's why
you want to kind of like have one back
in one forward you can't afford yeah
right now I'm gonna try to set this up
for you now you can't afford that
oh it's they're locked oh you just court
yeah thank you
oh man we're gonna go out I'll let the
match Sharkboy
we have Shark Boy going right back the
water play one more you should play one
more no well yeah I think we should play
one more we should go off on like a
fourth like them forfeit I agree but now
we're just stalling I hope this guy
quits or something I think he is trying
to I think we should just know he's not
gonna quit because then he gets like
let's just keep blowing him up okay just
bleed out the clock whoa that's weird
just be like I couldn't blow him up now
we're not gonna get goals that takes
longer on the timer what's he talking
about
oh he knows we're trying to kill him we
got to try a two-pronged attack Rob
don't know I tried I try to save it I
don't know he just wants to make it oh
wait
maybe we should practice our dribbling
some jookin yeah some jookin
I just wanna kill him all right I'm
gonna try this I'm gonna play goalie on
his goal yeah right yeah yeah who is
this guy
wait what about scoring ourselves
we're just playing keep-away no I'm just
playing ball possession huh
good job good job see he doesn't know
what's going on he thinks I'm trying to
score he's got no idea we're like saving
it you know whoops yeah you can't stop
me for like bringing it this way he's
gonna spawn over here
[Music]
ha ha ha Oh Touche you try to jump and I
jumped as well as like I'm in midair I
read them like a book like a book
alright we'll take the w-whatever enjoy
the frosty fest though got7 let's see
how many you get
sup C sup sup oh we're bronzed here
apparently no just me oh I'm gold whoo
Division 3 I know I know you're gold you
gotta get on my level 5 goals it's ok
you're the better player as our last
match of the frosty fest as mentioned
earlier 25% off ps4 switch hopefully get
on that hopefully it's a it's a win but
a hard earned win you wanna you wanna we
can make it harder ok no nothing doesn't
like that last match alright you know I
mean you go you go you got a boss I hit
nothing but they both have no boost so
this could be a long goal if you can
snipe them right here
I'm just blocking this dude I guess okay
you go run it if you can yeah just like
that
that's too much yeah it's trying to see
if I could subtly tap it off the wall
there that was not [ __ ] oh he blocked my
block I got a piece of Allen I only try
to run it for you it's kind of coming
tell me next time no oh god oh god
flawless flawless victory oh it's okay
somehow I didn't know be okay no problem
no problem no problem I'm so high I was
way too huh I made a bad read I was I
don't know why I was following me we're
playing doubles oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
one tap I'm on it I'm on it
yeah sorry trying to get away from it oh
he said it yeah I'm up there okay that's
fine
you have this kind of yeah I'm going for
it it wasn't worth it
oh that it's good yep sure
take it boost on the way
oh is that true Wow we beat the guys we
lost two below yeah yeah that other time
I didn't know so well that's great
that's great news I don't know why I'm
trying to make these plays Rob
this guy does not know how to make one
Oh
oh it's just right up it's a meatball
how they don't have to do it that you
can't go for it I'll stay back all right
it's all open yeah
party that's why you don't swarm ladies
and gentlemen yeah when you both go for
the ball and you don't make contact in
twos you're like pretty screwed unless
the other team just finds a way to not
take a good shot I'll stay back I
haven't been doing a good job
Oh get down get down get to the chopper
[Laughter]
feel like they're gonna for it see look
look how awesome my wings look Sara yeah
no feel like you need to change your car
look though that color scheme was to
match the winds I agree
but you're an angel you're totally right
oh he whiffed sure did
they need to cool oh my god that's a
that's a double whip that's gonna be a
baby no not a pop-up but you're there
I kind of it was too hot off my off my
car there there you go
are you
coming off oh good save
oh that's dusty you kind of you there
know already said it though okay get
down dude
it's set
buzzer else well nice wall though
oh come on that's all you if I sort of
I'm getting jocks oh yeah just like we
planned
they both swarm yep yep yep right back
to you I'm sorry
that's not good are you back scheisse oh
you would be neat ooh cool
oh no oh I almost got a piece welcome
one there goes to shut out a bagel the
bagel a you guys should drive in Reverse
the rest of the match says anvil one
okay I guess so sure
well do one goal in Reverse only I guess
and hope that this is really weird
oh this is really weird oh shoot I was
never one goal I tried last second oh
there's that ghost top of your time out
of that is hot that's not a smart way
all right we got we got too cocky not
too cocky
damn you anvil one filling our heads
with these thoughts
remember that's what this ionics guys
did to us though I do remember that when
we played the devs yeah that was fun oh
oh
oh I was trying to do a little Juke did
your uno mas porfavor alright good work
I won't you show where you can buy that
stuff exit to the main menu and we'll
show off what you can buy if you were to
accrue some of these snowflake
currencies from completing matches KK KK
you bought some wings you also bought a
crates so did I that's where I got my
decal from who I'm close so here's
frosty fest Rob can almost afford
another oh look at that it's all shiny
so right now I have 23 flakes get a
holiday stocking there or a peppermint
antenna or that's about it one more one
more match and I can get some these 25
yeah
but I'm thinking about this right here
so yeah that's what I look that's
another maybe what five five I think
about five to six so so just so you guys
know it's like roughly we're getting
anywhere from like three to nine coins
at one point I think that I don't know
this for a fact but it feels like if you
win and maybe like you do pretty well in
the match maybe you get more coins not
positive on that just happen that one
time when I got nine but you'll get them
regardless win or lose anywhere from
three to nine and for me I had to use a
Decrypter to open my crate because I
didn't have a key but you can buy the
crate the sanest secret santa crate
which has a bunch of cool new holiday
themed things right so yeah so yeah fun
so yeah I mean it's kind of nice for
like frosty fests and the Halloween
Festival one is like you can get these
items fairly easily if you just play you
know a few hours and you get to kind of
select which one you want post you
buying keys for maybe a dollar for one
not my sure these are actually so yeah
yeah as you see there yeah 13 days left
last until January the second on it
again today PlayStation and PlayStation
4 and switch have a sale 25 percent off
so get in on that if you don't have
rocket League yet ooh that looks nice
Yuletide listen to that listen that's
not as annoying as a hohoho
it's not out there what's winter storm
where's - you're right you're right Oh
like a modder
variant second a candy cane champagne
can't even see candy cane silent but
deadly
yeah SPD anyways that's our stream oh
those are just tire marks oh okay that's
our stream brought to you from our
friends over at rocket league thank you
guys so much for tuning in until next
time
actually tune in tomorrow for our best
of the year three two and one
that's gonna be at 10 a.m. where we
count down to our game of the year game
sports game of the year tune in to that
I think Rob you may or may not be there
tomorrow we'll see until next time
though thanks guys
later thanks Rob thank you XO yes
[Music]